what's up you little turds wait what is
going on we have the plaque yeah I just
got out of the vents rub it in your
faces I just got it at the bench rub it
in your face his name your sex tape
what something strange is afoot which of
these are real what lights what the hell
oh my god her precinct is disgusted dear
God
Hitchcock and Scully's desk oh wait look
at the plaques our heists dumb our heist
um of course not I was a stupid question
no Jake it says heists are dumb Terry
the Oscar professed liar goes to you
that's not an Oscars category what's
going on not to be harsh Sarge but
you're setting a terrible example for
your daughters and they're gonna grow up
to be total failures you take that back
no she's right Jeff and your children
are doomed where's the plaque over the
last time I don't know I've been working
here the whole time
ask them well actually we both fell
asleep and Jeffords never woke us up
coincidence I don't need this you're not
going anywhere
you sure to get away everything
get someone lock the door Oh Gina
of course it all makes sense except for
the parts I don't understand to the fact
that I still kind of think Terry did
this nope it was all me three weeks ago
captain Holt asked me to order a plaque
that read the ultimate detectives last
deem yes I did it and I ordered three
copies and a statue of Tyreese riding a
dolphin
is that relevant to my life yes once I
had the plaques i manipulated captain
holt into two things Boyle and his
partner all it took was six bottles of
disco see this is what happens when Jake
tries to wash dishes by himself
it's like he's helpless without Boyle
yes he is helpless without Boyle and you
fell for my trap like a greedy little
red easy yeah it was easy and the next
phase of my plan you knocked out your
two front teeth false teeth fake blood I
lost my real teeth had been severed de
Partie and fourth grade you made sure I
didn't remember that it was minute five
of seven minutes in heaven with Todd
Cohen when he bumped the wall and the
bowling ball fell on my face maybe I
just wasn't at that party was ID fake
the skating mishap I swapped out a dummy
plaque for the real one and I left to go
to the dentist
you convinced your dentist to help you
carry out the rest
now of course that going I came back
wearing the perfect disguise to make
sure I was never noticed by anyone
something so drab and uninspired feels
like it's gonna be a dig on me I wore
Amy's clothes there it is this is your
doing you and your male prostitute bill
is not a male prostitute I don't think
that suit is not drab it has a fun
salmon lining no Amy it made me
invisible and now that I had that power
every time one of you stole a plaque
I've replaced it with a fake and no one
had any idea until the lights went out
revealing a secret message heists are
dumb and we raced in here to blame Terry
and you trapped us but how did you know
he was gonna say heists are dumb Terry
says that about everything everyone
should wear suspenders belts a dumb
people should swim forward the
backstroke is dumb 30 grams of fat
hummus is dumb and now here you all are
locked up behind the glass like a bunch
of loser fish I bet you're wondering why
I did it
because you wanted to win no I had a
loftier goal in mind you do me a favor
and tell me what that says right there
the ultimate detective-slash-genius
detective can you imagine what that word
sounds like to someone who's not a
detective discriminatory
it's worse than segregation uh-huh too
far sorry but I think I've proved a
point and that's why we're changing the
name of the plaque forever
what do you know that Maddie is the
ultimate human slash genius thank you
and now I'd like to say a few words you
talk for like an hour when you had us
locked in that interrogation room I'm a
fair ruler your comment has been heard
but seriously you guys I just want to
say I freaking love you losers happy
Halloween take out your teeth
[Applause]
[Applause]
you